-Hey, guys.
We have some very exciting news.
All next week
we have the biggest band
in the world on the show -- BTS!
[ Cheers and applause ]
They're going to perform
a new song every night.
We're going to be
talking to them.
We got some fun games
planned, lots more.
And we're kicking it all off
Monday night
with a special
musical performance
with BTS, me, and the Roots.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
Let's just say
it's gonna be big.
-Big.
-It's gonna be explosive.
-[ Mimics explosion ]
-It's gonna be like TNT.
-Boom!
-It's gonna be...
I can't think of any other
words, but it's gonna be big.
So tune in every single night
next week.
It's BTS week
on "The Tonight Show"!
It's gonna be fun!